Senator Robert F Kennedy died 50 years
ago today I thank to all of you and now
it's on to Chicago and let's win there
Bobby Kennedy was assassinated at the
Ambassador Hotel in Los Angeles just
moments after he won the California
presidential primary shortly after his
funeral on June 8th 1968 at Saint
Patrick's Cathedral in New York a train
took his remains to Arlington National
Cemetery outside Washington DC
he was buried next to his brother John
up to 2 million Americans interrupted
their day to stand by the tracks and pay
tribute to the man lying in the train's
last car on it's 225 mile journey it was
asleep and my wife welcome to have him
she said I think I shot but it's amazing
50 years later it's true God John
Anderson was a campaign aide for Robert
F Kennedy in 1968 and managed the guest
list on the funeral train that day
I was struck by the size of the crowds
but every now and then there'd be one or
two people standing with a flag or sign
it was very emotional
still is also aboard the train
photographer Paul Fusco he captured the
faces black and white male female young
and old staring into the train window
mixed in age
and second color size
you're they John Malone who was 20 at
the time stood along the tracks in New
Jersey did it feel like a funeral or it
actually did the sense was that you were
out awake you were paying your respects
and just here to do that and stay
quietly waiting for the train to come by
and one of the houses here I could hear
a woman crying and as the train came by
she she just called out Oh Bobby Oh
Bobby
when did you make the decision that you
would go watch the train your line as
soon as I knew that the train was going
to be coming by this close I just felt I
needed to do it with people my Bobby
Kennedy need to be remembered nothing
has changed when Bennett Levin was 28
years old he watched the train pass in
Philadelphia we waited and we waited and
we waited for what seemed the pier to
Eternity the bridge was lying three deep
there wasn't a spot to be had what kind
of people were there just every common
day working people everybody seemed to
turn out in the crowd even though the
train was hours late stood there
reverently waiting for the train and you
know that it's in itself said an awful
lot for the esteem that the people held
Robert Kennedy in Kuantan today Levin
owns the car that held the casket fifty
years ago this is where the casket was
placed and because the door is so narrow
the window was removed and the casket
came in and there he took chairs from
the dining room but six chairs here will
hold the casket
the last card standing there and I see a
lady with a veil and she's sitting next
to a casket it has a flag over
I wasn't ready for that I just expected
to see the train and here I'm looking at
a lady with a veil sitting next to a
coffin that's carrying the hope of my
family black Americans police made
periodic sweeps up and down the street
tossing tear gas into the crowd during a
year marked by racial unrest from the
assassination of Martin Luther King to
riots in the cities fifteen year-old
Michael Scott went with his mother to
watch the train pass through northeast
maryland the fact that he was willing to
stand up for people who look like me
people who weren't privileged people who
worked in harsh working conditions and
spoke to me as a young man train was
carrying the remains of our last hope
[Music]
Stephanie Lange watched the train in
Baltimore when she was 24 years old she
went with her husband and her
two-year-old daughter I was thinking
about Ethel Kennedy the grief that she
was going through to lose a husband
it will soon be approaching the
outskirts of Baltimore when the train
came through that was the moment that I
stopped and paid my respect and I saw
the train come by and I put my hand on
my heart why did you make a page of
these pictures that was the moment in
our life that history happened do you
think that people would walk to the edge
of a train track for any public figure
today yeah why do you think that is I
don't think we had the respect that we
have today the train carrying the body
of Senator Kennedy arrives
almost five hours after it was scheduled
it became an event that was the end of
that adventure was a little piece of
American history that I had a very
little piece of
and it also gave me a lot of hope at
that moment if there would be a better
day
boy John there's something very powerful
and very beautiful to know that 50 years
later your death your life meant
something on the planet that's people
still remember and admire and remove to
tears by your passing that's yeah very
strong and who would we walk to the edge
of a train track yeah it was a very
powerful having those conversations what
was said about about him that he felt
the same empathy right for white
working-class as for blacks as for
Latinos as Native Americans and that in
this era we yearn for someone who could
unite such a diverse group of people the
way he did the way he felt empathy for
all of them and he felt it in his bones
when Martin Luther King jr. was
assassinated the famous speech with
Bobby Kennedy get stands up on the back
of a truck and extemporaneously gives a
beautiful eulogy he didn't have a
speechwriter he just came out of him and
that's what people connected to yeah but
it leaves me sad knowing that that woman
like many people feel who would you go
and stand on the railroad tracks at but
we still hold a place there and now
we're just looking some of us in America
and so we still strive for that yes
roughly damn great it's beautifully done
we all said any music
beautifully done well it was a team
effort